what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
members of the Rob core I have been
reading Captain America for 20 years
I've been reading him since the 90s and
I got to tell you next Spencer's run is
probably the best I've ever read I mean
some of the stuff that I've seen in here
some of the events that have taken place
the page reveals and so on a lot of them
are just shocking I mean granted and
Brubaker's reveal of Bucky Barnes return
wasn't seen at the time it was one of
the things you had to be there it was
like it was a talk of the town like oh
my god Bucky Barnes is back it was nuts
it was beautifully done and he was
incredible but for all the pomp and
circumstance of Ed Brubaker run I would
say that Mitch Spencer's is blowing it
out of the water now keep in mind a lot
of this comes out of the events of
Avengers standoff Pleasant Hill the
events of Civil War - and that's one of
these a lot of people have asked me is
what's going on with Steve Rogers right
now how do we square that circle so I
want to go ahead and take a moment with
this and I want to talk about this again
we already have videos on Steve Rogers
but everybody's video was someone's
first video so those are guys who are
familiar with Rogers so far bear with me
for a second because a lot of people who
aren't so with more role going into
all-new all-different marvel Steve
Rogers was basically still the old man
yes really what he was who was the old
man of Marvel he was a director of
shield before the events of Secret Wars
by the time all new all disma Marvel
kicked off he was basically like their
field field commander their field
liaison for the superhero community on
behalf of shield because he's the core
of a superhero community everybody
always considered it to be that way
because of that Steve Rogers along with
I guess really his uncanny Avengers team
and the traditional Avengers team
responded to the events of Avengers
standoff which took place in Pleasant
Hill it was basically the revelation
that shield was using where they were
remaking a cosmic cube what is happening
during this event though there were a
lot of people took place a lot of things
that came out of it the new run of
Thunderbolts for example but throughout
all the events that were taking place
there was basically Steve Rogers
regaining his youth and the reason why
was because Nick Spencer was wanting to
move into this next level of
storytelling with regards to Hydra
Captain America and so during the events
of Pleasantville I guess during the
events of standoff we ultimately found
out that was shield basically remaking a
cosmic cube the Cosmic Cube had become
sentient just like we always do it took
the form of a little girl and then red
skull I guess the Cosmic Cube was
attracted to Red Skull just because of
the fact that the cube as it had been
formed was a fragment of multiple cues
one of which had been used by the Red
Skull so with his memories being
implanted on it so on and so forth the
Cosmic Cube travel
to him like a daughter meeting her
father for the first time and the result
was that Red Skull used the cube to
recreate Captain America's backstory and
so what happened is basically reality
has been altered the history of the
universe has been changed so that
instead of Steve Rogers being an
American who wanted to fight on behalf
of America during World War two instead
Mick Spencer is going through an
unfolding his backstory over the course
of Captain America Steve Rogers now of
course one of these we learn here in the
beginning of all this is that as a Hydra
student you know within hydras training
camp Steve Rogers is really a standout
star in terms of his intellect
physically he's the same Steve Rogers
that we always remember he's not the
most physical guy he's not the fastest
as as was always a problem he's not the
strongest he's a last guy you would want
on the front lines of any conflict but
in terms of his mind he's such a
prominent member of the community
that the result is that he's basically
moved to become the head of orientation
that when new kids are brought in to the
Hydra training facility that Steve
Rogers acclimates them to how things
function to how things worked the issue
is that because Steve Rogers is really
like the weakest of everybody who's
there a lot of the students have have
gotten really irritated about this and
what happens as Nick Spencer use of this
as a platform to kind of jump off in
this story and focus on the idea that
see Rogers has a hidden ally and that he
has this hidden ally because he realizes
that you can't do everything on your own
you always have to have somebody in your
corner now what this does is this
coincides with two things happening at
the same time the first is Steve Rogers
and Natasha Romanov of fighting through
a prison we don't know exactly why all
we know is they're basically fighting
through a prison going against different
prison guards so on and so forth the
other half of this is that the Red Skull
is basically creating a Hydra army now
it's not an army in the traditional
sense like we're going to march through
Europe instead what the Red Skull is
doing is he's going into countries where
the citizens feel disenfranchised and
he's turning them into revolutionaries
and so what he's doing is he's basically
having them rise up against their
government and try to cash them out the
funny thing about this though is that
for the Red Skull he's got a much bigger
picture here in his mind why have his
revolutionaries fight looking in it he
can have like shield fight the battles
for him and so what happens is that in
the midst of this year this major
conflict in sokovia he basically has
several of the generals own guys bring
the general into a safe room and then
the Red Skull begins talking to him now
what the Red Skull says is that in his
mind yeah he could he could have the
whole fight take place because keep them
and the Red Skull still has the mind of
Charles Xavier and so he basically has
Charles Xavier abilities Granite's it's
not global Charles Xavier powers weren't
really global he needed cerebro for that
but he can still control the mind if
anybody he wants to but what he says
here is that for for this guy general
Camile I guess have a camel I'm not sure
how you look at his name but essentially
what's going to happen is the red
Scrolls forces are going to lose red
school is basically going to throw the
battle and the reason for this is
because if this guy if this general is
considered to be or looked at as the one
guy who defeated the Red Skull then
Shield will come beating on his door
giving him anything he wants will give
you training will give you weapons will
give you whatever it is you want if you
can continue taking this fight to these
various revolutionaries and basically
eliminating the Red Skull for good and
what the Red Skull says is he can in
turn use those resources that shield is
going to send over operate from the
shadows and secrets and basically turn
the forces of sokovia into his own and
use those against shield as well as
other countries and continue to solidify
his own arrangement his own I guess you
know kind of creating this power
structure in Europe very similar to what
Adolf Hitler did during World War two
and so the reason why or at least what
we learn the reason why I Steve Rogers a
Natasha Romanoff are Anthes present is
because they're tracking down a guy
named general dent and general Den's was
the guy who ruled sokovia before general
Kamil came into power whatever it is was
so because of that they're basically
bringing that guy to shield bringing
general dents to shield and what shields
going to do is instead of following what
Red Skull thought that she was going to
do and fund this general that you know
supposedly defeated Red Skull instead
they're going to back dens and they're
going to have dens essentially create
his own revolutionary force now they
don't expect it to succeed but what it
is going to do is just going to give
shield the ability to gain more Intel to
gain a better understanding of what's
going on and to basically force the Red
Skull to fight a war on two fronts for
the intention of being able to pull it
off now switching back to the backstory
of Steve Rogers this is when things get
really really wild because you know with
these kids that are basically jealous of
his position they consider him to be
lame they ultimately ambush him and of
course they start beating him up they
start humbling but then a kid jumps down
from the rafters and starts fighting
alongside Steve Rogers and as I was
going through this I was like dude this
is mind-blowing this is this is
absolutely insane and this little bit
coincides with Steve Rogers right now
talking to talking to Erik Selvig what
Steve Rogers says is look it's important
that you're in on everything it's
important that you're in
what's happening a sources backstory and
the current events basically leading it
leading up to this huge reveal you know
he says look I kept you in the shadows
long enough I have a secret ally I have
a guy that you don't know about a guy
who's in my corner and as they continue
to go through and as they continue to
talk we end up finding out that with
Steve Rogers in his younger days the
ally that came to its aid was not Bucky
Barnes like we would expect it to be you
know like a Hydra version of Bucky
Barnes instead it was helm use emo and
so because of that like Zemo is his
closest friend is his ally from when he
was younger and so it's like I was
reading through this I was like oh my
god like Baron Zemo is his friend their
allies here and it absolutely blew me
away I was just like this is this is
this is this is insane now from here we
pick up with really like an invasion of
Chitauri you know the Chitauri alien
race now on its surface this seems
totally irrelevant it seems like it has
nothing to do with anything it has
everything to do with everything because
this is how Steve Rogers fortune the
shadows one of these things where he
just distances himself and nobody
considers or nobody even thinks
let's see Rogers hand will be caught in
the cookie jar instead what happens you
have you know Steve Rogers fighting
against these guys we've got Carol
Danvers fighting against us invading
force shield is facing off against them
and then we pick up with a girl named
Admiral now afro was a SHIELD agent
during the events of Avengers standoff
and a lot of these old artifacts that
were wildly powerful in the history of
Marvel Comics we're basically just
confined in this museum because it was
basically designed to be this place that
was half tribute to see Bagheera I was
past creating a false life for the
various films to keep them under control
and that's one of the reasons why I was
so controversial and the Cosmic Cube of
course is basically controlling the the
environment around them so they would
always believe that what they were
seeing was absolutely real but during
Admirals of him to basically help well
this this uprising by the various
villains that were being held in
Pleasant Hill she had found the the
quantum bands now the quantum bands of
course are d the signature item
belonging to quasar and is how he uses
his powers but what the quantum bands do
is they tap into what's called you know
potential energy or the potential energy
of the entire universe meaning that you
know if a if you were in the Marvel
Universe and you were to throw a
baseball if that baseball was sitting
still it has potential energy when you
throw it it's got kinetic energy you
know the energy of movement the
potential energy did that
all has is what the quantum bands tap
into essentially it taps into all the
energy that exists that's potential
that's never actually being used now it
does that by way of a different universe
and it gets kind of weird and crazy but
that's the long and short of it the idea
here though is that Averell is basically
the universe's protector that's exactly
what plays are was the quasar was one of
several heroes who played the role of
protecting the universe Adam warlock did
that captain universe did that Marvel
Captain Marvel did that it was always
their role was to be a universe
protector that was back during the days
before Marvel really like revamp their
cosmology with annihilation prior to
that it was always just these small
stories here and there but these
characters who existed out there in the
cosmos maybe you were reading them maybe
you weren't but at this point we jump
back to the past again and the reason
why is because we take up with Steve
Rogers and he'll New Zealand I get it's
wild to see the two of them as friends
but Heinrich GMO has appeared here the
father of family now the reason why this
is significant is because in normal
history Heinrich vemma was an enemy of
Steve Rogers and hydrogen was actually
the person who was responsible for the
explosion of the you know the drone
plane or whatever was that led to Steve
Rogers being frozen in ice for 20 years
and led to Bucky Barnes you know being
picked up by the Russians but following
this the reason why Heinrich Jimo is
here is because there's a meeting
between Heinrich Zemo dr. fennhoff the
the head instructor of the school as
well as the school's recruiter and
Daniel Whitehall I'll keep in mind
Daniel Whitehall while you guys may
remember him from shield in the comics
he played a much different person he was
very much tied into Hydra but he was
really more of like hydras top warrior
you know they're their top fighter but
the reason why they're here is because
Hydra is looking at like Adolf Hitler
Baron von Strucker and a basically
saying those are not the guys that we
need those are not the guys who really
represent hydras ideas the person who
really represents hydras ideas who
really represents the idea of Hydra
trying to basically take over the world
by way of convincing people that they're
superheroes is Steve Rogers Steve Rogers
is the guy we need because he has all
the moral fortitude to lead the world to
believe that he's a good guy when in
reality he's working against its best
interests now from here we basically
take up again with this Chitauri army is
launching another attack and we
basically have a virile as quasar go out
and just demonstrate her power in the
sense that she uses this energy to
basically wipe away all these these
Chitauri soldiers but it's also this
huge ride act it's being read by Steve
Rogers to Maria Hill and to Carol
Danvers and the reason for the
because I basically abandoned her
training in the middle of the discussion
with window Vaughn to take off and
engage in this fight and Steve Roger
said we literally just finished civil
war two like we literally just finished
this major Civil War event and already
you guys are trying to harness the power
of some young grill so you can use her
for your own ends why in god's name are
you doing this all you guys are going to
do is bring everything down around you
but at this point we follow Steve Rogers
back to his base of operations with dr.
Erik Selvig and we actually learned this
Steve Rogers instigated this whole
attack he's the one that led to the
Chitauri invading Earth and the first
place now there's a reason why Steve
Rogers is doing this he's got a long
game that he's playing right now and
that's why this run is so good it's
because it's not like Steve Rogers is
doing these small things and each one
has a goal instead they may have
temporary goals there's a much bigger
picture that he's looking for and we'll
find out what that is at the end of all
this but the way that he was able to get
the Chitauri forces to show up here is
that because they're basically like a
hive they all have Queens you know
they're like termites they're like ants
they have Queens and the idea was that
Steve Rogers had basically taken some
and brought them here to earth so this
is Hari would show up here on earth with
the intention of trying to get their
Queen back and so it was really him just
just more or less leading them there but
at this point we pick up with you what
we're really another the trial of Maria
Hill now the trial of Maria Hill is not
the most important part of the story all
this really is is just her being court
martialed
because the events of Avengers stand off
the way was handled and her basically
being ousted as shields director that's
all it really is she's kicked out from
the role of being shields director
instead what happened here is we also
get a little more backstory with regards
to Steve Rogers with regards to Baron
hell museum oh it's really the two of
them just kind of growing up you know
sort of coming into their own what we
also have here is Maria Hill announcing
that she's been a great director that in
the midst of everything that's happened
she's always held the world together
she's held the country together you know
she's used to intelligence in a way
that's always been functional not only
that and this is really kind of crazy
here she's very cocky she's very
arrogant and how she conduct yourself as
if there's no way this is going to go
anywhere but her benefit she's also
basically created what she can salt what
she calls this shield is essentially
this great big huge giant forcefield
that revolves around a planet Earth that
nobody can get in and nobody can get out
if it's activated and so what happens is
we jump back to the past with Steve
Rogers and we find out that because of
the fact that Daniel Whitehall because
these various members of Hydra look to
him as the greatest of them
that their goal is to basically have him
infiltrate the United States and the
reason why he's going to infiltrate the
United States is because there's a man
by the name of dr. Abraham Erskine who's
currently working on a super soldier
program and so at this point we jump to
the US that's what I love about this you
know an ex-ninja doesn't waste a whole
lot of time giving us these great little
opening moments where he immediately
catches our attention and of course what
this does is it gives us kind of like
this diary of Steve Rogers as he's
writing back to Baron Zemo as well as
some kind of explanations about things
that are kind of filling in the gaps
between the end of the last issue that
started this one but basically he's been
assigned to kill dr. Abraham Erskine
he's been assigned to poison it and the
idea here is that if the US doesn't have
a super soldier program that you know
Germany will inevitably win the war
that's someone with these super soldier
powers basically like a Captain America
so to speak would help win the war for
the Allied powers so because of that
Steve Rogers has been tasked and it has
really come to the realization that dr.
Abraham Erskine always goes to the same
diner for breakfast and so the time
eventually comes where he gets a job
there and says all I need is a moment
all I need is a second to basically
poison this cup of coffee and get him
killed and so what we do is we pick up
with a fall out of this this trial of
Maria Hill and we learn again that she's
essentially been asked that she's been
booted out and so what happens is we
have the world security council sitting
down with Sharon Carter and saying we
think you should be the director of
shield now the reason why this is such a
huge deal the reason why this is so
significant is because Peggy Carter at
least as has been retconned you know the
aunt of Sharon Carter Peggy Carter had a
major role in helping to build shield in
the younger days you know back during
World War Two she was a freedom fighter
a really fun on the side of the United
States alongside Steve Rogers there was
a great big huge history that not to
mention that Sharon Carter herself agent
13 has a very lengthy history and
fighting alongside shield she's worked
directly alongside Nick Fury back before
you know he killed a watcher and then
became the unseen she's been a major
part and so forth for the world security
council it just makes sense right I mean
just promote Sharon Carter to the
position of director
the issue with this is that Sharon
Carter says I don't really want I don't
want that role I do not want to be the
director of shield I don't really feel
like I'd be the person best suited for
that position instead I think it should
go to somebody else and so what happens
is we pick up with Steve Rogers you know
arriving home speaking with Sharon and
she says yeah you know they offered me
the director often this would be the
director
and of course is a huge congratulatory
celebration between the two of them but
she says no I didn't I said I don't I
don't want that job you know I told them
that you should be the director of
shield Steve Rogers and so when I saw
this they blew my mind because I was
like they're inviting the wolf into the
henhouse like they're putting a Hydra
agent into the position of the director
of shield not only that it's the best
Hydra agent that's ever existed and so
again jumping back to the to the path of
Steve Rogers you know in his younger
days as he's working in this diner he
begins to sort of have this conversation
with Abraham Erskine and Chester
Phillips this is really really cool the
way it happens because Chester Phillips
was originally the military general that
was there that was part of the whole
project Bieber thing Abraham Erskine the
scientists behind it and next Spencer
plays this out very much the same way in
terms of Erskine and Rogers first
encounter in the sense that Rogers kept
being turned down turned down turned
down all the time eventually it drew the
attention of Erskine and Erskine asked
him why do you want to fight in this war
so that and Rogers response was because
it's the right thing to do was basically
because if you find evil you have to
stamp it out no matter where you go and
this in this new backstory that he gets
it's almost identical it's almost the
exact same thing he wants to be part of
something bigger than himself now again
this is Steve Rogers the Hydra agent
playing Abraham Erskine like a fiddle
more so than that there's a guy who
basically comes in and steals the purse
of the waitress from the diner of course
Oliver chips inside and Steve Rogers
leaps into action and immediately takes
off track this guy down is able to beat
him up of course the guy gets away but
Steve Rogers gets the purse and Abraham
Erskine says this is it this is the guy
this is a guy with the moral with the
moral fortitude with the courage to be
the super soldier that we're looking for
is part of Project Weaver what an
exciting time to be a Steve Rogers fan
right now because it's great to see his
character go through your changes it's
great to see his character fluctuate
it's great to see new concepts being
being involved coming it'll come back
and eventually he'll go back to being
the traditional Captain America that we
all know and love where he fights on
behalf of freedom and yadda yadda yadda
and all that stuff the same thing that
we've been seeing since his inception
you know he'll go back to all that but
until he does it's going to be one hell
of a ride and I am excited to be a part
of it what if you guys are new here to
come in to sway make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the Rob
port if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later please
[Music]